on the first of november two thousand
and six former russian spy alexander
litvinenko left his home in muswell hill
in london and traveled to the Millennium
Hotel in the center of the city there he
met two former KGB agents and Ray
Lugovoy and Dimitri Compton they had a
pot of tea waiting for him he drank only
a small amount during their 20-minute
meeting within hours he felt ill within
days he was in hospital he died in
intensive care 22 days later of
radiation poisoning a major operation
was launched and within days numerous
locations across London linked to the
former spy and the two men he met were
being investigated for possible
contamination that investigation was
widened even further when very small
traces of radiation were discovered in
two British Airways aircraft at Heathrow
Airport by the end of the inquiry
thousands of people had contacted an NHS
helpline dozens of buildings had been
tested and dozens of people tested
positive for contamination the
radioactive substance used was polonium
210 which can occur naturally but is
primarily produced in a nuclear reactor
only around 100 grams are produced each
year almost all of it in Russia